the chickpea dishes of hummus and
falafel are staple foods throughout the
Middle East so of course they're on the
menu at nice arbiters restaurant he
comes from Syria like many of his
customers they fled to Turkey to escape
the Civil War at home i decide i decide
i must work because the syrian people
also missed more things here like bread
like bitter arrived in Turkey from
Damascus with two suitcases he was on
the run from the Syrian secret police
with his restaurant he was able to make
a new start and offer the growing tide
of young Syrian refugees an opportunity
to build their own future to leave them
in streets this is what we want exactly
they want them work in some good places
like human this is what we want because
we suffered before them and we didn't
want them suffered like us now beter has
six more restaurants in the center of
Istanbul and his are not the only
businesses on the Bosphorus owned by
Syrians increasing numbers of refugees
are arriving in the Turkish metropolis
to escape the camps in the border region
and the Turkish government tolerates
that but not all of the Syrian refugees
are able to build a new life in Turkey
10 year-old Khadija tries to remember
the letters she once learned she was
only able to attend school in her
hometown of Aleppo for one year before
the war started I can write a few words
and compose a simple letter but I want
to learn to read and write properly and
I want to go to a proper school
instead she sits around with her mother
and three siblings in a damp basement
apartment in an Istanbul suburb her
father works as a day laborer earning
the equivalent of around 400 euros a
month it's not enough to send Khadija to
a private refugee school whenever I pass
a school in Istanbul I get very sad
because I can't send my children to
school in a way they've lost four years
of their lives but at least Turkish
authorities have given refugees like the
courtiers IDs that allow them to get
medical treatment for free but there's
no doctor that can help with the cold
that enters the makeshift coverings on
the glass 'less windows and there's no
prescription for homesickness I really
miss my home especially my neighbours in
Aleppo and my apartment I have no idea
what condition it's in a safe here in
Turkey but no country is as beautiful as
Syria there are some 300 thousand
refugees in Istanbul from Iraq as well
as Syria those who suffer social
rejection and are unable to find work
usually want to continue west to Europe
but for that they need people smugglers
to get them across the border to Greece
or to Italy we call the Syrian smuggler
in the Turkish port city of Marcin
pretending to be potential clients it
costs four thousand eight hundred
dollars per person usually we take
between five thousand and five thousand
five hundred the ship's seventy seven
meters long a freighter that can sail in
any kind of weather this time there will
be 1,000 passengers on board the captain
will not leave the ship don't worry
he'll only get his money when all the
refugees have reached their destination
the Mediterranean port of mersin some
1,000 kilometers south of Istanbul is a
hub for people smugglers
in the past desperate refugees used to
risk crossing to Europe in fishing boats
now they do it in freighters ready to be
scrapped this former journalist from
Damascus who wishes to remain anonymous
wants to use a smuggler to get to Europe
he no longer has a passport his wife and
children are in Lebanon now he's trying
to earn enough money for the crossing
despite the risks if you're trying to
escape death you don't care how
dangerous it is and Europe is forcing me
to place my fate in the hands of
smugglers there's no legal way to do it
I'll probably go alone and then get my
family when I've been granted asylum in
Italy or someplace else
these are Betar plans to stay in
Istanbul he says Arabs and Turks have a
lot in common in terms of culture and
religion and he feels at home in Turkey
you look for country respect you see you
give you peace give you life give you
war give you a warm give you medical
this is our country this is our hope I
must say that but only a very few of the
1.6 million Syrian refugees in Turkey
are as lucky as Nizar Betar or have his
entrepreneurial spirit